non-minimalists
you're right we are uncomfortable with
stillness we
meaning all of us yes but the hanza
are not uncomfortable with stillness in
fact it's a great
source of experience i won't even say
pleasure for them
it's a great source of experience for
them is
or maybe a great source of joy for them
in it's because it's part of the
everyday life the reason we're so
uncomfortable with it
is because it's not part of our everyday
life now here's what
the problem with because i agree with
you i was that way i'm not that way
anymore
but i i but there's still remnants of it
for sure
but in 2014 is a great example that so
2014
we basically donated a year of our lives
donated the wrong word
but i mean we didn't make a bunch of
money we we went on a tour and all the
money we we
did exactly what we wanted to do and it
was awesome yes
but it was not very still it was
constantly in motion oh my god
but it also wasn't obligated we got to
do it yeah but
with the moving so quickly and then
stopping fast like in your car
you get whiplash if you do that if you
slam on the brakes or you
ram into someone and that month i spent
in san diego
quote doing nothing yeah it was
disorienting because it was it was like
whiplash in a way
now now the hadza have part of their
everyday
now it's not a routine as in the sense
of what is your morning routine no it's
just part of their existence
right it is stillness but when stillness
becomes part of your existence
all of a sudden you
there's a serenity in it but not when
it's
prescribed to stillness and that's what
i did back in 2014
i was i went and did stillness right you
can't
do stillness it reminds me of uh there's
a good point one of my favorite david
foster wallace lines i was talking about
this on um
this is the dfw segment of the
minimalists private podcast we did a
whole dfw segment on uh
bex's podcast it's called how to love by
the way howtolove.show it's patreon only
if you
are interested in hearing a lot of
things that i've never talked about in
public
ever um oh my god anyway uh how to love
his name her podcast we're talking about
there's a line from one of his short
stories
that uh it's about hummingbirds i
believe or maybe it's about bees
but i think it's hummingbirds in order
for a hummingbird to stand still they
have to move very fast
um you've seen that right hummingbird
were there they look like they're
staying still right but their wings are
flapping
a million miles a minute and that was me
in december
of 2014. yeah i i was doing
stillness i was doing nothing here i am
i'm doing nothing i am doing nothing hi
i'm josh i'm doing nothing i would do
nothing harder
and that was the thing but now there's
stillness built into my everyday when i
talk about the
the calendar now i work a lot there's no
question and this week in particular
i had a few yesterday was a
5 a.m to 11 p.m sort of day that's the
first time i've done that in a decade
damn now i i was because i saw the
finish line and i'm like i'm not going
to wait till tomorrow i'm not going to
punt this like
and so i just finished it all up but
even in that there was a great
joy in it because there was stillness
throughout the day
like i went for a walk to go around my
block is exactly half an hour for me
from my door to my elevator
around the block up the stairs in the
elevator into my door
is like 29 minutes and
and i did that several times with no
music no podcast it's just just the walk
the stillness now the world is still
moving around me
and so stillness isn't a literal
stillness of motion
and it's also not stillness of the mind
because that's impossible yeah don't
think right now ryan
that's what it's like to say do
stillness it's like saying don't think
right when i'm talking about stillness
it is a mental
stillness and when i'm writing that's
when i
actually experience the most stillness
the state of
no mind not mindlessness
not mindfulness but the state of no mind
a flow state one might call it
there's a particular kind of stillness
there and and so
i don't seek that out so much as i
as i recognize it for what it is
it is an experience and that is all and
i've gotten a lot more comfortable with
it in the way that
you would get more comfortable with
going to the gym so to extend
the metaphor or to use a mixed metaphor
here back in december
2014 it was like i had never worked out
before
or i had i took the last 11 months off
of working out
and then i hit the gym three times a day
every day
it was like well what am i doing i mean
this is this is awful
yeah and and that's what was happening i
i was
doing stillness as opposed to like
well making room for
the stillness for the boredom
and once i started doing that because i
learned from that
that 2014 thing and i've got a lot
better but especially in the last
six months last 12 months but especially
the last six months
i i've really felt
a peace that i have never felt before
and i think a lot of that has to do
we can call it stillness we can call it
eudemonia whatever but
but there's a peace and that never comes
from a doing
right i can't i can't do my way to peace
i gotta work harder on being peaceful
it's like the u.s trying to bomb people
into peace
on this what is that
is it irobot he's like
we're here to rescue you
that's like the robot like destroying
everything in his
path stay quiet while we rescue you yeah
it's yeah it's it's silly when you say
it out loud obviously right
right did you enjoy this video if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com
the minimalists today